From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Okay, this is Roan Cullen for about 20 seconds.
Today is Friday, July 15, 2011. My name is Joe Manier of the Southern Oil History Program.
I'm a professor at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Bill. I'm a videographer, John Bishop,
a conducted interview for the Civil Rights History Project, which is a joint undertaking of the Library of Congress.
And the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture,
which delighted to be in Philadelphia today with Dr. John Churchill.
Thank you, Dr. Churchill, for inviting us to come by and spend some time with you. It's an honor of privilege.
Thank you.
Well, you're more than welcome.
I thought I'd start today just talking a little bit about Dr. Charles,
and coming up and building up it.
Okay.
All right, where should I start? I was born at a very early age.
I think that's a good way to begin.
I guess I can think of a couple of incidents that were life-changing.
I'll talk about those.
When I was in about the first of all, I was born with a very extreme case of myopia.
So I went to a site saving school back in those days. They had a site saving program.
And when I was in about the fifth grade, I experienced my first set of circumstances where I face discrimination.
And it's interesting because I wasn't discriminated against because I was black, but because I was a site saver.
In that school, we had...
It was in a regular school. In fact, it was in T.M. Peer School, which is a school in North Philadelphia.
I believe it's at 23rd and Canberra, if I remember it correctly.
And at that school, which was a, quote, regular school, they had a site-saving program.
And of course, what site-saving was is that we had larger print...
You know, we would print larger, bigger lines.
And we had a safety patrol.
But there was segregation in the school. The regular students were where they were.
The site-savvers had their own lunchroom. Site-savvers had their own safety patrol.
I was on that safety patrol.
The problems of the segregation, if you will, and discrimination was that a regular safety could tell any student,
site-saver or regular to do whatever they needed to do, but site-saving safety.
And I was one of those could only talk to site-saver.
So when I was in the fifth grade, I got very upset about it, talked to one of my teachers.
And she suggested that I run for student council and raise the issue there.
So an interesting thing occurred. I did run for student council, got on to student council.
And in fact, kind of ended up being president of student council, and forgot completely about the issue that sent me there.
So I took that as a learning experience as I reflect back, that the error that I made in fifth grade was to think that,
to forget my identity. And my identity at that point was a site-saver.
And my role was to make sure that I fought for the best interests of site-savvers.
Well, I got caught up in the fun of being accepted by the regulars as the school president and lost that focus.
And so that lesson, which of course I didn't learn in fifth grade, but I certainly learned today afterwards, helped me to focus as an older person.
By the time I got to high school, I figured out where I had screwed up.
Another event, when I was in seventh grade, that could have changed my life forever, was being bullied.
And people talk about bullying today. Gee, whiz was I bullied. There was a sky.
I won't mention his name. He may he rest in peace.
But he used to beat me up every day. And my first way of handling it was to try to run away from him.
Every time I tried to get away from him, he would beat me and make it worse because I avoided him.
The next thing I tried was to fight him back. That was futile.
He was bigger, better, and better than me. And so he would beat me worse.
In deep frustration, I talked to some of my student friends of mine and I said, hey, I talked to my friend and said, look, what am I going to do?
He, my friend, referred me to a young man who was a Ukrainian descent, who told me that he take care of it.
Now, I got to tell you about this guy. I'm not going to mention his name, but I got to tell you about my Ukrainian friend.
He was a Nazi. He could just about quote verbatim, mine comp.
He loved the ground-hittler walk-doney, talked about him all the time. But there were some weird things about this young man.
It's nice to hear that.
This is in, yeah, the weird thing about him is one, he wasn't blonde, he wasn't blue-eyed, he was brown-hired, and brown-eyed.
And he wasn't a German, and he was a Ukrainian.
The second thing is his favorite teacher was Jewish, and not the German teacher we had on staff who was a rabid showmanist.
And to show you how she felt about the black students in her class, she told us all we had to do was fly airplanes while she taught the white kids on the other side of the moon.
And Russell couldn't stand her.
His best friend, oh I shouldn't mention his name, but it's okay. His best friend was not a German, but an African-American.
And of course, he didn't come to the United States because he benefited from Nazism.
So I kind of anomalous his whole interest in it.
But anyway, what he did was he told me he helped me out. So the next day he brought me a zip gun.
And he brought me some 22 caliber bullets, and he made the gun for me for free and gave me the bullets for free.
And that day I went home and determined how I would end the life of my torturer.
Without so much thinking about it, I mean I put the gun in my pocket, went to school the next day, and this day I looked for my tormentor.
And I found him in the school yard and asked him, why are you always messing with me? Why are you trying to make my life miserable?
And he knew that I was too bold for my recent behavior. So he said, oh you must have a gun. You must think you're going to hurt me.
And I was going to pull the gun out, and at that very moment, as he was coming toward me, I for the first time thought, if I do this, I'm going to jail.
And the worst thing that can happen, worst in jail is I would disappoint my mother.
And so I didn't pull it. He beat me that day. But he beat me. I've described it as the way he beat me was like a person who does their due diligence.
It's like, because you did this, I have to, to save face, I have to do something to you. But it was not at the level that he usually would beat me.
It was sort of like a show. He beat me. It wasn't hard. It didn't hurt. And he walked away. And he never bothered me again.
But six months later, he was dead. He was a member of a gang, and he got killed. So what I learned from that was that I could have taken an action that would have ruined the rest of my life.
And until the moment it hit me, I didn't even consider all those things that I considered on the day that it happened.
I would say that those two childhood memories, aside from the fact that those were the memories that really shaped the way I think shaped, helped shape the way I deal with problems, looking for solutions other than killing people.
And the other person who was really strong in my life was of course my mother, who...
Sure.
...who just went to follow up on that one question before you talk about your mom. Was that really white or black?
He was black.
So, and of course in those days, the only notion I had about race in that time was the way my third grade teacher talked to me.
Because one day, and by the way, the guy who gave me the gun, we had gone to school. We stayed in sight saving from second grade through eighth grade before people go to junior high school.
But in third grade, this German teacher said, looked at me and said, how's your mommy?
And I felt funny about it. So when I went home and told my mother that the teacher said, how's my mommy? And it was something about the sound and the tone that wasn't cool that my mother said, when you go back to school tomorrow and ask her how's her mommy?
But I knew there was something up, but it was a mixed group of kids. I mean we had black and white students. So I didn't have a sense except for that teacher and the other thing.
There's something else that we had to deal with in school when I was going to school, was our teachers and counselors, except for the...
I had two teachers that I remember. Mrs. Maines and Mrs. Corn. These were teachers who were very supportive, always encouraging us to go do whatever we needed to do.
But there were counselors and other people who would constantly tell us, you need to go to trade school.
You need to go to, you know, don't try to go to college. You'll never be able to get anything. You'll never be able to go anywhere.
And it was one guy, when I was in the ninth grade, I remember him very specifically. One teacher, our social studies teacher, and I give him credit.
He had his ideas about, you know, don't even think about it. I mean, we just tell the straight up. Don't even think about, you know, go to college if you want to, but don't think about getting the job or being able to do anything.
What I will teach you, he didn't teach us social studies, but what he taught us was, and I give him credit to this day.
He made us get newspapers, and he taught us about the stock market. He said, you know, take practice, buy some stocks, you know, this is all theoretical.
And he would make us follow those stocks every single day, so that when we got out of his class, even though we knew no social studies, we knew how to invest in stocks.
So I give him credit for, at least giving us a skill that we could, and he was very clear about, you know, the way money is made in the United States is nobody gets rich from working a nine to five job.
So the way you're going to be able to do well is to get into the stock market, start small, and just keep doing it as a side thing. Keep doing it, keep doing it, and you'll end up.
If you believe what other people tell you, and you go after a job, and think you're going to work for 25 years, and you'll live on whatever they give you, the watch, and whatever.
And I give him credit for instilling in us. He gave us more social studies than the curriculum called for, but, but I really appreciate that. That was a lesson that was really helpful.
I was going to go in and talk about the other major influence of all my life, which came up in that moment when I decided I better not use this gun.
I absolutely loved my mother, and I know every kid loves his mother. But because we were, we developed a friendship.
She was, she only had gone to high school, but she was well-read, she was, she loved music, she was a musician, and we could get into these deep conversations about different things.
And she was very open, she was very, she looked like a traditional person, but her mind was non-traditional. She was open to new ideas, she was open to, she never made excuses for injustice wherever they were.
She was just, you know, she was a person who, you know, read readers' digest, you know, read, you know, did this kind of stuff. And so she, she, she was a tremendous positive influence in my life.
And she always, one of the things that she taught me so well was always examine your motives. Whenever you think about doing anything, think about why you're doing, you need to know why you're doing whatever it is you're doing.
It may look like it's good to somebody else, but you need to know what your motives are, and examine those motives and make sure that they're in line with what's right.
So, so she was, she was my best friend.
So, I'll try to just one second.
Okay.
Okay, we'll back on after short break.
Our church will, you mentioned about other musicians, and I know that music would be very important to you as well.
Can you talk a little bit about her music and how you came to...
Okay. Yeah. She was, she went to temple to take music courses because she was, she was a singer, and she had an opportunity as a singer.
I don't know who the, the, the impassario was, but there was somebody who heard about her and offered her an opportunity to do whatever operatic.
People do, and she turned it down on the, on the basis that she wanted to raise her children, and she wanted to, you know, just do that.
But in the meantime, she had a choir called the Village Concert Choir, and we lived in the heart of North Philadelphia.
And on summer nights, you could hear this choir of maybe 10 to 15 people singing Bach or Mozart or some other thing, Negro Spirituals as well.
It was a fully rounded thing, and so there was a, there was a sense in which she, she brought, if you will, culture to the neighborhood.
And people would just come outside and just listen as, you know, as the group was rehearsing and singing.
She also had, you know, did individual voice lessons, piano lessons and voice lessons, and I kind of learned, there was a time when she got ill, and there were students coming, and I kind of figured out how I could fake, well, fake during the teaching.
And it was easy because I was around a lot, and I would hear, you know, Saturday after Saturday, people coming, making the same mistakes, and so what I would do when they're doing their, you know, so I would kind of, I got into a habit of knowing what the right chords were, what the right changes were, what the right notes were, so that when I had to sit in for her, the student had no clue that I couldn't play.
But I could say no, that's E sharp, you keep, you know, I mean, I'm sorry, that's E flat, you keep playing E natural, and that's why it doesn't work out, you got to play E flat, that's better.
So I would sit there and the student would think, oh, this guy knows, you know, he's young, but he knows what he's doing.
Well, her music influenced me, I was very interested in music when I was in high school, by the time I got to be a senior in high school, I was in the Simon Gratz High School choir, I used to direct it when Joy going Smith, who was our directoress, she was notoriously,
may she rest in peace, but she was notoriously late whenever we had our concerts and recitals, and so, she was, I would be the one who would conduct the choir on those occasions when she was a half hour late and we needed to go on and do what we wanted to do.
So I got very interested, I, in fact, I want a music scholarship to Temple University, and we had this group of teenagers who would sing, you know, we did pieces, in fact, we won summer, we put together the operetta,
Gilbert and Sullivan's trial by jury, and we just kind of put it together and went up there in Germantown, I was still living in North Philly, but there was a Germantown women's club or something, there was a place where there was a stage, and we just did the whole thing, with the costumes, got people to come, it was a kind of fun thing.
So that's one of my happy music memories. The other thing too is I started playing...
It's a great studio for the business, I think, for the bells, Chinese, and the alley.
Okay, we're back after a short break for the chiming of the clock. Dr. Chuchba, you were talking about the performance and moving towards Temple.
Okay, I, I, I want a music scholarship to, to Temple University, on two grounds, I think, more so than my musical ability, because, because of my eyes, I didn't really see the notes on the paper very well, I'm extremely, I was, was extremely near-sighted.
And, but I had a, I had a great ear, and if you played it, or I heard it, I could, I could get it.
And I, I never formally, even though my mother tried to teach me, I, I learned how to read music by following the notes.
I mean, it was, if there was a jump I jumped, I mean, I mean, and once I knew I was in the key, and if it wasn't, you know, if it wasn't,
a flat that should be natural, or, you know, or, or, or a note that should be sharp, I mean, I could, I could pretty much, if, if I, if you gave me a piece of music, and I, and you started it, I could pretty much do it.
And it, it, it appeared to people as if I could read extremely well, but I'm just using, using my head.
And in fact, maybe reading music is just that. But anyway.
It's like follow up 59, that you're starting a sample?
Yeah.
Follow up 59.
So I went to Temple, and stayed there for about a year and a half, moved, left, I used, used the word, kwituated.
I kwituated from Temple University, and had an opportunity to just move to New York and get away. I was about 19 at the time.
And it was time for me to leave Philly. I mean, I, what's a 19-year-old still living in his mother's house for? That didn't make any sense to me.
So I moved out, and moved to New York, 318 East Forestry. I remember that, that address lived in the, in the East Village.
It's called East Village now. It was lower East Side when I was there.
And really, really loved it. It was, it was a whole new education.
I mean, I ran into people who were Marxists and poets and musicians and artists and black nationalism.
Just a whole range of people. I mean, I met French people and, you know, it's just a whole,
group of people who were very different than people I grew up with. And, and it was just absolutely wonderful.
I was just enamored. I was, you know, I'd go to the pink pussycat and, in, in the village and, and listen to poetry and, you know, go through the holes that it was just,
it was having an honor at work and I tell you. And I met, met musicians and I used to do, while I was in New York.
I did some playing. I was a jazz pianist and did some playing, but mostly I was listening and just kind of learning and kind of enjoying the thing.
Absolutely. Go ahead.
Would you have said before you arrived in New York, was your household a political house there for you, something of kind of a political kid?
No, not really. I was the sort of the radical. I used to have these little discussions with my mother about the church, for example, as being gutless and irrelevant.
And, and she, you know, her thing was, hey, I love Jesus. You know, you got any problems with him? You know, I agree with you 100% church is.
So I mean, I couldn't do much arguing. You got any problems with Jesus personally? No, not really. But what Christians, yeah, I agree. Yeah, the crusades were horrible.
Yeah, I mean, you know, he would not have sanctioned that. So that was the thing. And before I left, I guess I should say this on the religious side.
When I was about 17 or 18, I became a Muslim and Ahmadiyyat Muslim. And say how cool my mom was. Her thing was, hey, whatever gets you to take a bath and put clean clothes on.
I'm fine with it. So, so, um, she was, you know, you want to wash five times a day. Please, be my guest. So she was, she would let me, she would do some of the recipes that I'd learn, you know, get, and she'd cook them for me and enjoyed it.
She was so comfortable in her own skin and in her own beliefs that her thing was explore, do what you need to do. And if, and if you can tell me Islam is better than Jesus, I'll switch.
I mean, she was, that was her line.
I had joined her towards Islam.
I met a guy who was really sharp. He was young, maybe a year older than me. And he'd come around and he would talk about black history and he would talk about Islam and Islamic history and stuff that went on.
And you know, it's like, wow, you mean the moors that I've read about were black people and they created the culture that is in Spain today when I look at all those beautiful things out of Spain that black people, you mean to tell me the stuff I read in my textbooks that blacks have not made any contribution to culture and the world, except for their dances and menstrual shows.
Wow, that isn't so many. That was the catalyst. And it was, it was a different identity. It was, it was, it was fun.
He was young, I was young and it, and by the way, my Muslim name is Yahya Abdul Hamid.
And so that was who I was for a period. I'm very much John Elliott Church released, but I always give people credit for what they bring to my life and how they enrich my life.
You'll find I'm very eclectic in my learnings and my appreciation for stuff. Anyway. So I did that and then I moved to New York and through all of this.
And it was one of the reasons why I loved my mother so much. She was so open. She was never threatened by anything that I came up with.
She was just very supportive of me. And after I, when I went, when I had been in New York for a while, I had this opportunity to go south. This is where the SNCC story starts.
I had this opportunity. I was working at, as a janitor at Columbia Presbyterian Medical Center in Harlem.
And there was, there was this bus that needed to go down to somewhere in Georgia, but it wasn't Atlanta.
I know there was a SNCC was having some kind of retreat and the bus was supposed to be delivered to them. And I kind of lost my job.
And there were people living in one of the negative sides of running into all these wonderful people that I met.
People were always looking for a place to crash. They never paid rent. They just came, ate my food, stayed in the spot, brought their friends.
And I was at a point where, you know, there were like five people in my apartment that I was responsible for the rent for.
And it was rent control. I think it was something like 50 bucks a month. It was ridiculous. But anyway.
I decided, I don't have anything to do. I'm not working. I'm not planning to go back to school now. I mean, sure, I'll get on the bus and take a ride.
I mean, it was purely a matter of taking a ride. So I went with some other guys. And we went down. And when we got to Georgia, I was really impressed by the young people that I met, who were my age.
And white and black in there, like all college students and they're talking about freedom, justice, inequality. And I'm like, okay, I can buy this.
And so I hooked up with Reverend Charles Sherrod, who ran the Albany Park. In fact, I just heard a red that I believe he's still in Albany.
I haven't seen him in many years, but I was under his tutelage and under his wing. I know I was a mess. But anyway, at the time I went and I went to Albany.
We would, and I was assigned to Lee County and Terrell County. And later, I also worked in, and I don't remember what county it's in.
I don't remember whether it's Lee or Terrell or some other county, but I worked in, it must be maybe a Sumter County, America. Is that in Sumter County?
I'm not certain about that.
Okay.
I had, well, some interesting things that happened when I was with Snake. First of all,
I'm going to lay out the carrot.
Interesting things. Charles Sherrod was an interesting guy to begin with. And he was just die hard integrationist.
I mean, he just, the whole motion of black and white together. So it was interesting with my experiences when I had been in New York,
what I didn't mention, while I was in New York, and I had this Ahmadiyya Muslim background. And then when I got to New York,
I would spend days and evenings up at 125 feet in 7th Avenue in front of Michelle's bookstore and listen to the nationalists give their speeches.
And I met Malcolm X and I went to Temple Number 7 and stayed. And I was just so impressed. This guy was so brilliant.
And that's nothing. I mean, I like smart people. I just, I love smart people anyway.
And after the service was over, I went up to him and I said, Minister Malcolm, tell me about your life.
And he said something that really, he said, my life is irrelevant. Where I've come from and where I am now is irrelevant.
What matters is that we as people get our act together and forge ahead and do something for ourselves and stop waiting on other people to do things for us.
And that just the humility. And he was hot stuff in terms of the press. I mean, everybody was vilifying him. But he was hot stop.
I mean, everybody was, you know, Malcolm, Malcolm. And his whole demeanor was, I don't matter. Getting your head straight matters, getting the rest of my head together matter.
And that just stuck, it just rang in my head. So when I went down to SNCC, I was a black nationalist by the time I went down to SNCC.
And Shiraud understood you that way. He understood me that way. Yeah, I think, I think he understood me that way. Yeah, he had to because I had a white partner.
And when I went out with my white partner to register people to vote, the black people that we dealt with would always look to the white partner because they were dealing with the power symbol.
And from a purely ego centric point of view, it was bad enough to be in the north and ignored by white folk. And it was just intolerable to be ignored by my own folk.
I could take it. So I went back to Charles, I said, look, man, I need a black partner. I don't want to do this with a white partner.
And I had no problem. This was not personal. It was business. I mean, I loved every person that I met in SNCC.
It wasn't that. It was that I needed to work with a black partner. And I had a way, I believed that I had a way of getting more young black people to register to vote.
And so, Sherrod came up with this deal. If you can get more people, I'll let you do that. But if you can't register more people than you can with the partner that I gave you, you got to go back. I said, fine, I'll do that.
So, I got a black partner. And that's when we start working in America. And at the time, this is really fun stuff here.
At the time, if you can believe this, there was a gang war going on in America's Georgia. I mean, we're trying to register people to vote. And in the black community, you got these two teenage black gangs at war.
And I just went in the middle of a gang fight and started screaming and hollering. You dumb.
And they just stopped. I said, this is what white folks want you to do. Why are you doing this? We're here to help you to register so you can get some power for real. Stop fighting each.
They stopped gang war. And we were able to recruit them to first register themselves. And then to negotiate a peace treaty and help us go out and recruit people to register and vote.
If I had tried that, Norfolk would have been dead today. But anyway, so that was kind of a fun thing.
So, oh man, that was, and it was the black talk. It was the black rap. It was the reason the rationale for voting is not to integrate.
The rationale for voting is to build a power base so you can elect people who look like you to office, who will do for you, what people who don't look like you will do.
And that, so that was, for me, that was the beginning of what I call black power. And that was not looked on lightly or nicely by the SNCC folks.
But they tolerated me. And I give Charlie Sharad a great deal of respect for putting up with me given his own views.
And I think that, and he was always, you know, you've rebelling. You rebelling.
But he allowed me to be who I was. And so that was, you know, that was a success. I stayed with SNCC. Then there was the summer came up.
The summer came up. The, the, where we're, where we're, where we're, where we're 64. No, that was 63.
It had, or maybe was it early? I think it was, it wasn't 63.
Yeah, because that's, because I believe, well, I must have come up after that. Anyway, I was in Mississippi doing, when did, um, lose?
That was the later that was 65, because that was, that was on the way back from Montgomery after the summer.
Okay, well, I wasn't there. I know my sense is that I left SNCC in 63. But anyway, I was in Mississippi.
That's what your, that's what your printed resume said.
Yeah. Well, you know, I mean, I may have the, but I, I know that I was in Philly by the summer of 64. I know that.
I know that I was in Mississippi at the Kofo Freedom School teaching literacy in Greenwood, Mississippi. I know I was there.
And I think the reason that we were sent there was because there was an assault. And I'm thinking it was the three civil rights workers that caused us to move in, because we were moving in.
I thought after that. But, you know, my, my, yeah. Well, anyway, there was, there was stuff that went on.
No matter, before you, before we ship to Greenwood, because I want to ask, tell me a little bit more. I want to ask,
Southwestern, how, Southwest Georgia was mean and nasty, hard. Yeah. And you guys were in the thick of, yeah.
A lot of difficult stuff. Yes. Terrible violence. Absolutely.
How did you manage through that? How did you, um, tell yourself to get up in the morning?
Well, it was easy to get up in the morning. Fear will get you up.
I was never, I have never been so scared. In fact, I blame my high blood pressure on my experiences in Southwest Georgia.
Um, it was, it was scary, but at the same time, here's what's so awesome.
When you're with people who are committed to something that's good, and you're not the only one who's afraid,
everybody's scared, you start singing. I mean, for the time I was there, Jesus was the man. You understand?
I was a Muslim, but I did not pray to Allah when I was in Southwest Georgia. I prayed to Jesus.
I had no, in fact, I had to nerve, and one, um, at one church meeting,
I deacon prayed some, some nonsense, and I stood up and I said, you know, we're in this real situation,
and you are, you don't believe what you're talking about. You know, I'm not just kind of castigated this guy.
I mean, you know, young, arrogant kids will do that to you all the time.
Um, but anyway, I kind of castigated him for, you know, and offered instead a real prayer based on fear,
and look, God helped us. The clan was outside. Talking about burning the church down,
we don't need the old father God in whom the world, no, we need help, you know, get it real.
Get to the point. God knows what that is. So that was interesting. That was an interesting experience.
But yeah, the whole crew, I always separated my ideological concerns about blacks and whites from my personal stuff.
It was never personal for me. I love people, you know, and, but anyway, good.
In this time, did you develop a sense of an opinion about SCLC and Rung King?
Oh, God, yes.
Well, I mean, as part of it because of youth and part of it because, I mean, as far as I was concerned,
Martin was, you know, he was too easy, he was too light, he was not on point.
Well, part of my anger, which I picked up from, Snick folks, was, here we are in Albany trying to clean up after his mess.
He wouldn't even stay because it wasn't working. Snick stayed and continue to try to work when the cameras weren't there.
And so that was a source of, in fact, I have to admit that it was only at his death that I was wondering why I was mourning so much.
Because I always held against my issues with him about Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party and the role that he played,
and trying to get them to line up to the Democratic Party and not let them do what they needed to do.
So, I had real issues. It was only at his death that I said, oh, God, this was my brother.
And I may disagree with his tactics, but, you know, unfortunately, I got to respect him after his demise,
but had very little respect for him prior to it.
We have a little bit of a little bit.
Okay, we're back after a short break.
Can you tell me a little bit more about some of the things that stand out in your memory about the people you met in Southwest Georgia and the communities you went into?
Yeah, I think the communities that most affected me, well, first of all, I fell in love with the people in Albany.
I remember our mass meetings on Monday nights if I'm not mistaken, again, but it was one regular night every week.
And there was one time when a preacher came to the meeting, and he started talking about the fact that the governor had given him a letter that allows him to travel anywhere in Georgia on the roads and not be less than he can give it to the Georgia State Police or something happened.
And somebody in the crowd, and I think it was Charlie Sherrods watching.
And then he started talking some more, and then you heard another watching.
And it was sort of like knowing that this is a plan.
Here's a guy that's trying to tell us cease and desist.
And so different people would say different things, and different times as he's talking.
So that it's more and more clear that this guy is on the other side.
He's just sitting in here to try to keep us from doing.
And then we just started singing, and we sang whatever the song was, and just drowned him out.
The whole church ain't gonna let nobody turn me around.
And we went right into it.
And it's still a favorite song of mine.
And he just went and sat down.
So that was the thing.
The other thing in terms of community, you would think that the people who made the change
and who had the guts in those communities were the young people.
It was not so.
It was the older folks who were determined that they would not have their children and grandchildren
and live the life that they lived.
And it used to make me angry that the kids didn't want to hear what we were talking about.
By and large, except for America.
America was a special case.
But the kids in the communities that we were dead didn't want to be bothered.
Older grandmothers would listen to us and would want the best for their kids and their grandkids
and they were the ones who were taking the risks.
I remember one incident that really upset me.
I've never really gotten over it.
We were in one community in southwest Georgia.
And I don't even remember whether it was Lee County, Terrell County, somewhere.
And we were called out to this house where the mother told us that the sheriff,
who was notorious, Dunnoway, was just a notorious horrendous guy.
He had grabbed her son who worked in a white store doing something.
And the baker, a bakery truck driver, had raped the boy's sister.
The sheriff, and I guess the boy tried to tell the sheriff or tried to tell,
the sheriff pulled out a gun, put it to the boy's head, and said,
if you open your mouth about this, I'll blow your head off.
And I will tell the guy you're working for that you molested his daughter.
And I was livid in the feeling of not being able to do anything that the law,
the person who represents the law, you just, how can you go to the sheriff who says,
I'll kill you. And the other side of it is, I won't kill you.
I'll let the guy who's, who's, you'll be lynched.
And I remember feeling that pain and that, that angst, that rage.
And there was nowhere I could put it.
There was nothing we could, we couldn't tell the other frustrating things
when the FBI guys would come down.
They did nothing. You could talk to them. They went back and told the sheriff,
whatever you said. They weren't trying to protect you. They were, they had no interest.
It was just very frustrating to work in a situation where all you had was your colleagues.
The only people who believed in what it was that you believed in, and the people.
And again, I go back to that thing. One of the things that kept me in,
I was scared enough to run the first day. I've always told people that I have a back problem.
And if you look at it, you'll see a yellow streak all the way.
But I felt, I can leave, but they can.
You know, I can't, at this point, I just can't, I'll be scared with them
because they have a lot more to lose than I do.
But I remember that, and that was extremely frustrating, extremely frustrating.
And we'd hear about atrocities every day that never came to the light of day.
And we'd hear about them and people would tell us about them.
Some things we'd even see, and there'd be nothing you could do.
So that was the, that was the gripper.
We moved on to Mississippi from South America, Georgia.
Did you go in a mood of, and bivalence about your prospects?
America's been something of a success, and you go forward.
But all this other is pattern of wallessness and violence.
Dispare.
What was your, what was your mood that you took with you to, and the Mississippi,
your perspective on this, this style of effort to change things?
Well, I was really, let me just say this to you, there were two strains that were going on in SNCC.
Two camps.
There was a direct action camp, which was focused around demonstration sit-ins.
And then there was the voter registration camp.
I chose the voter registration camp because I saw that as a way out.
I couldn't see demonstrating as a way out.
I saw no future in demonstrating.
I couldn't see myself getting beat in the head for nothing.
If I'm getting beaten ahead because I'm trying to get people registered to vote,
at least there's something, but to get beaten ahead to eat some food that somebody's probably spinning,
I couldn't, that just didn't come back.
So, I was happy to be involved.
I mean, I was appalled that black folks had to take a constitutional test.
And my god, lawyers can't understand the constitution.
You can get all, I mean, there are experts in constitutional law who disagree about what something means.
So, but it was a challenge to just work with what I could work with.
It's like when you're in an impossible situation, this is another lesson that I learned.
When you're in an impossible situation, you just do what's in front of you.
I mean, I couldn't even think about future.
I couldn't think about where is this going.
It was just, I'm here right now.
These folks are here right now.
I'm going to give them the best I got.
I want to encourage them.
I'm going to help them.
I mean, I didn't even think through to, even if they know that the right answer is the people when they take the test, they're going to tell them you got it wrong.
I didn't even go there.
It was like, give them what you have.
Give it all you got.
And just, it's like, put one foot in front of the other.
Don't think about the outcome.
Don't worry about the end of the road.
Just take steps.
And that's what was my mindset.
And I was quite, I had consoled myself with this.
I was quite, I guess in the real sense, that was probably one of my snake experience was probably the first time I was living in the moment.
Before then and after then, I've always thought about what's next.
Where is this going?
Where is it leading?
What's the end game?
I'm always thinking about it right now.
I'm thinking about what's the, not for this, but other things that I'm involved in.
Where am I going?
And where is the end game?
And how do I make steps to guarantee that I get there?
But in Southwest Georgia and Mississippi, I got the privilege, and I can say it now looking back,
the privilege of actually living in the moment.
I couldn't go beyond that moment.
I had to live every minute of it.
And was, was, was satisfied to do that.
Was Mississippi, in essence, a continuation of the same type of experience or in substantial shape?
Well, the difference was, of course, that I wasn't doing direct getting people to go down to the polls.
I was teaching people literacy.
And it was, it was just a different, a different mode.
And one that I quite liked.
In fact, that got me when I came back to Philadelphia.
I started a school.
That was sort of my introduction to, hey, you like teaching.
Why don't you do it?
One more question about all that before you turn, turn our focus towards Philadelphia.
Are there folks who stand out, you can mention Reverend Sherrod or are there other folks who stand out?
I'm also interested in, of course, the interesting gender and racial dynamics,
because you get some white volunteers, you get some women in the mix, and interesting thoughts,
you think that coming?
Yeah, well, Sherrod sticks out, Diane Nash Bevel,
who was just sort of the sweetheart of the movement.
Bernice Reagan, who was not only singing, but brought something to the movement.
Bernice sticks out, Faith Holtzart, who was in our camp.
Sticks out, Bob Mance, who I worked with, who was, I'm telling you, sticks out.
And again, you're dealing with a memory.
Man, 50 years ago, but there are certain people who, and I'm trying to think,
when this is all over and you're going, I will remember other names.
But those are people who, and then there were community folks,
Eddie, whose last name I don't remember, but I worked with Eddie.
Eddie put up with a lot of this from me.
I teased him a lot.
I won't tell that story, but anyway.
But there were, oh well, Dory Ladner and Joyce Ladner.
It just comes.
But there were just, they were,
and John Lewis, and I'll say this, what I disagreed with John Lewis's view,
but I respected him because he, if you awaken John at three o'clock in the morning
and ask him what his principles were, he would tell you whether he was asleep, awake,
he would say what he had to say, he would stick by it, and no matter what criticism he got,
he would not come back at you, he would let you do that.
And I just, and to this day, I respect John, I mean, John Lewis would have to do something absolutely horrendous.
I mean, he'd have to do something.
I mean, he'd have to kill 50,000 people.
And the first few people he killed, I said, well, you know, you got to be some residual one.
But he would have to really do something, really atrocious for me to say, that's not the John Lewis.
I know, I, he was a kind of weird inspiration.
I disagreed with his views, his view about us together.
No, we're so full of force, I like that, but it, it, it's just the integration.
I had, issue, I saw a difference between justice and integration was not necessary.
I saw justice as necessary and justice, and people can choose to integrate on a personal level, that's fine.
And, but the, the economy has to be open to people and people need to have, you know, opportunities to live their lives without being held out.
But that's not integration, that's economic justice.
And so I had, you know, I'm a category person.
So I had separate categories, but what I loved about John is that he was passionate.
I mean, this was stuff, not, this wasn't a script that he, he didn't say what he said because the cameras were there.
This is, this guy talked this stuff when he's sitting alone with you.
He said the same thing in front of the cameras, he would not back off, he would say what, and I just respected him for that.
And loved him for that.
So he's a guy that, which shows you can disagree with somebody and really, really respect them.
And, and he's want to take my hat off to still.
What, what collection of factors drew you back towards front open since you picked?
Ah, here comes the other story.
There was a point that I got in, Nick, where I, it was like, look, this is not working for me.
This is not, I went back to Atlanta, and there I joined the Nation of Islam and became a black Muslim this time.
And I joined the mosque in Atlanta, and I was, I was trying to recruit sneak people to the mosque.
And Jeremiah X was the minister there, and I immediately started trying to do some organizing in Atlanta in a place called buttermilk bottom.
At the time, buttermilk bottom had no paving on the street, the very poor black community.
And my theory was, because I was a true believer in the sense that I felt that the black Muslims could do, were, were exactly what black people needed.
They needed to focus on developing themselves and stop trying to be nice to white folks.
Let's just do what we need to do.
And so I, I was active in trying to organize buttermilk bottom.
And for the mosque?
Yeah, well, actually it was, when I say for the mosque, it was, yeah, I guess it was.
And Jeremiah was very open to my ideas, because my thing was, look man, we don't need to have everybody being black Muslims.
That's not, shouldn't be our goal to recruit everybody.
We need communities in Atlanta who will stand up for us, so that when you make a pronouncement, and the press starts messing with you, you've got community people who say, hey, we think he's a great guy, and we support what he has to say, and that will make them back off.
And so he said, okay, he let me do that. And so what I try to do was to develop some kind of small little economic program.
I hated Selim Muhammad's speech newspaper. I like Selim Muhammad's paper, I've never been a salesman.
I tried and failed miserably, both in insurance and something in securities. But anyway.
So I tried to organize young people, and I had to get permission from the Chicago headquarters.
And when I tried to get permission from Chicago, I was turned down.
And that's when I first started feeling funny, because we're like, wait a minute, then you're not what you're advertised to be.
Because I came on the advertisement that you care about us, and you want to see us develop.
And we're talking about businesses, and we have an opportunity where we can give kids, they can sell papers and make money.
I don't need to do that, I can work at something else. I'm not selling papers to make money, I'm selling papers to get the word out.
So in the meantime, I met some, I started going to Atlanta University and talking to people, and trying to recruit college students for the month.
And my view was a little bit with my friend DuVois, and we got a talented tent that we needed to have.
So I was able to work, and we got some other professionals in the mosque, which I thought was a kind of big deal.
And we gave three of them and me got together. I was nowhere near where these guys were.
We had a mathematician, we had an economist, the guy was working on his PhD in the economics.
And I forget right now what the other one was.
But I mean, these are guys who have studied, and who are at the university, and who are Muslims.
And they came up with a project to just be a little bit more proactive.
We've got an opportunity here. We had Jeremiah, so when anything happened in Atlanta, the press would come over to Jeremiah, what do you say?
I mean, that was like a big deal in those days. So we'll listen to these other people, but we want to hear what you have to say.
And so anyway, these guys came up with this proposal and flew it up to, I mean, I expected mine to go down. I mean, who am I?
These guys flew it up to Chicago and it got shot down. And at that moment, I continued to be a Muslim.
I loved Jeremiah because he was just a good guy. He had, he was very personable. I mean, I'd hear him preach and say certain things.
And then we would talk privately. And he was just, he was just a good guy.
So at that point, I was losing interest in the black Muslim movement and ready to come back to Philly.
And it just so happened, it just sort of happens, that he got transferred. They wanted somebody else who he didn't like to take over Atlanta after he had built it up.
We doubled the size of the mosque. And he got sent to Philadelphia. It was just natural. He said, hey, John, come with me back to Philly.
I'll make you, because I was Secretary of the mosque down there. I'll make you Secretary of the mosque. It'll be okay.
I came, come back to Philly with that in mind. And what happened politically, there was somebody else who was the Secretary here.
And then the politics, Jeremiah had to, and I know he didn't just tell me that, because he was really straight with me. He would tell me, look man, I don't remember one time.
I got very emotional about the messenger. And I was talking about how wonderful he was. He said, he said, John, get a grip.
John, you're not going to lie to me, you're just a guy. Don't tell anybody I told you. Don't get carried away.
And that he would tell me that. I just appreciated his honesty. So I knew when he told me you'll be Secretary, when he got back, he came to my mother's back.
I said, I'm back at my mother's and he said, John, I can't make you Secretary. The messenger wants the guy that's there to stay. It's out of my hand.
So I said, okay. And immediately, I think I was back in town, maybe a week or two, and I hooked up with the Northern Student Movement.
I mean, I had to be, and I went to North Philly, and I was familiar with North Philly, and I went over to an area of North Philly that I hadn't been in before around Ridge Avenue, Ridge and Jefferson.
And there was a building available, and I said, hey, we need to come up with a project in the Northern Student Movement that is a library, we call it Freedom Library, NSM Freedom Library, which will have books buying about black people.
Because my argument was the reason that black people are not functioning the way they should is because they have little self-esteem, they don't know their history, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And at this point, I had completely discounted the whole notion of racism. I mean, I didn't address it that way. I mean, just all my meetings with my communist colleagues didn't help me with that.
I was busy dealing with other issues, but anyway.
So I put in a proposal, I went to the Dolphinger McMahon Foundation, and asked for a grant that same summer, there was a riot in North Philadelphia, and every store on Ridge Avenue got broken into except Freedom Library.
That, because it was a storefront, and we had to globe with hands around it, and it just said NSM Freedom Library, and it wasn't attacked, which was just kind of interesting, because they got the Barber Shop next door. Why are you going to hit the Barber Shop, but anyway.
So after the riots, Dolphinger McMahon came through with a $1,200 grant. I guess it was a lot of money in those days. I don't remember.
And then, that was like 64. So when I left the nation, I was still in the mosque, but I was not active. I mean, I'd go on Sundays, I supported Minister Jeremiah,
because he was a friend, he was a really good guy. And then the stuff happened, and I'm kind of fuzzy about the dates, but Malcolm had left or left?
I'd left the spring and six years ago.
And so I went up to New York, I met with him, Malcolm.
Oh yeah, oh yeah. And it's like, okay, let me help hook up the Philly chapter, and the guys.
Anyway, people I met in Philly who was supposed to be part of this thing were, I don't know who they were, I'm not going to say they were agents, I'm not going to say they were the shakiest people I had ever met.
So, you were supposed to be associated with Malcolm.
And so anyway, I joined the Organization of African American Unity, and I was supposed to put a picture of Malcolm in the window.
Well, when I did that and word got back to Jeremiah, he went to my mother and he said, please tell your son.
I mean, that was the time when if you got out of the Nation of Islam and followed Malcolm, you were writing a death sentence for yourself, you won't get yourself hurt.
Well, I'm glad that Jeremiah was my friend, because he told the people of the food of Islam, don't touch him.
And he begged my mother, please talk to John, don't let him continue with this stuff, he could get hurt.
And he was pacing up and down. She told me when I talked to her about it later, he was pacing up and down the floor.
I can't be there to protect him every step of the way, you know.
So, the mosque had lent me chairs, had given me chairs and tables for the Freedom Library and they just came and took them back.
But they didn't touch the building, they didn't touch me, they followed orders, which I saw.
So, to this day, even though minister Jeremiah has passed away, he's another guy who I absolutely love, respect.
I got to tell you one of the incident with him that comes up later, there was a time when I converted to Christianity.
It was around 66.
So, yeah, it's within that timeframe, but two years later, because that was 66, I converted, but this was like a personal conversion type thing, where I had an encounter, where I realized that,
Jesus was real and it was really, I wasn't in church, I mean, this is a house in my house.
But it came a time when I had to debate Jeremiah X.
And it was the funniest debate that you ever want to see, because I stood up there and talked about how all the good things I learned from the honorable Elijah Muhammad, how great Jeremiah X was, what a friend he was.
I mean, I just told the truth, I learned so much from the, I mean, every encounter, I mean, I don't leave an organization and then trash it, because there was good stuff that I learned, I learned about myself, I learned about possibilities for us that I would never have gotten any other, never would have gotten it in church for heaven's sake.
And so, at that debate, I just talked about, I just preached Jesus, basically, and said, hey, the honorable Elijah Muhammad is good, when I was a Muslim, I believed in, in a law with all my heart and soul, but I didn't have an internal witness or knowledge that God was with me.
And so, when Jeremiah got up, I mean, this is a public scenario, and the fruit of Islam is standing around wanting to hurt me, because how dare I debate with it, I don't know who set the debate up, I didn't.
And Jeremiah stood up and he said, he said two things, one, I should tell you this before, before we had the debate, I called Jeremiah when I had, because he knew I was out of the nation at this point, and I called him up and told him about why Jesus experienced, and he said to me, he said, John, because of a friend, he said, if I knew, Jesus was what you told me, he is now, I never would have trashed him the way I did.
I mean, that's just the level of respect between us, he knew I wasn't playing, and so anyway, when we had the debate, the major argument he made was, he said, this is the first time we have had a Muslim to convert to Christianity, most Muslims are converts from Christianity, I mean, who would that much?
And he said, the worst thing he said was, you can tell by looking at John, we won't have anybody else who does that, people laughed.
But that was, we maintained a friendship, I didn't talk to him that much afterwards, but, and that's why to this day, I mean, I have warm, fuzzy memories of, of Minister Jeremiah Shabbat,
he was just a good guy, he was just a good guy caught in a situation where he was, because he was good-hearted, I think he was pushed around by the nation.
They like cold-blooded people who could get it done, and that's why they got rid of Malcolm. He's trying to protect, hey, look, he was too sincere, too honest, too real,
to, it's like people who go into an organization, look at the mission statement, say, wow, that's a wonderful mission, and they go do it.
And the people in the organization say, well, we don't really want to do that, we just say we want to do that, you're going to cause problems if you really do that, so that's where that went.
Maybe, maybe, maybe, more to say about your reaction to his killing in 665?
Oh, oh, my goodness, I was devastated.
I was devastated.
One of the things I learned from Malcolm, and one of the sad things about what people were expecting from leaders in those days, people came to you,
and if you were supposed to be a leader, you were supposed to have answers.
So nobody comes to you and say, how can I help? They come with criticisms of what you're trying to say, okay, you know, I'm the time kind of guy, if I see you're trying to do something, I'm going to say, alright, this is what you need.
Okay, we need to talk about policy.
If you're going to do this particular thing, then we need to talk about policy, or you need to talk about whatever it is that's going on.
And okay, I can handle this segment here. I'll do this for you, Malcolm, I'll do this. I can handle this.
And then you're expecting other people in the room to say, well, I'll handle this. They're all like, what's you going to do, Malcolm?
What's you going to do? Nobody's taking any responsibility.
So I was pretty devastated at his death, and you know, again, put his picture in the window window, and, and, you know, it's just one of those things.
But one of the things I learned is that, and what upset me the most was the people who said, I remember being a black Muslim and talking to people about the nation when I was all going, ho.
And their thing was, yeah, we love Malcolm. If he wasn't with the nation of Islam, we would follow him.
So I took note of those people, and when he left the nation of Islam, I said, okay, he's out now. He's got this community organization that we're trying to organize, and dealing with issues that affect people's lives.
You know, this isn't rhetoric anymore. It's about now trying to, you know, he's at his epiphany, and he's, he's seeing that, you know, it's not going to be based on race.
He's, he's, he's trying to, you know, still help the, the people who need the most help.
Oh, well, you know, and so the same people who wouldn't take a risk then wouldn't take a risk afterwards. And so I learned a lot about human nature.
And I'm clear that people who aren't willing to be afraid with you are, are no help to you at all, because whenever you're trying to make a change, I don't care what the issue is.
There's always this scary part where, yes, you could fail. Whatever the object is, you could fail, you could be made a laughing stock.
But if you feel it's the right thing, even though you are afraid, there's something about taking that step in spite of how you feel, you do it.
And there is vindication in it, the winner lose. I've been in fights that I've lost, and I don't mean physical fights, because I lost all of them.
But I mean, you know, struggles, community struggles that have really not worked out well.
But what has made me feel good is I was in it to win it. I took a principle, what I believed to be a principal position.
I went on record with that position. And if I lost, or we didn't get what we wanted, I can still sleep well at night because I was on the right, from my point of view.
I was on the right side of the issue. And the way history works is eventually it comes back around, and people decide to do the right thing at some point later on.
And when they go back and check the history, they said, oh yeah, well, he was for this 10 years ago when it wasn't popular.
So I don't make a big deal when it goes, oh, I just say, yeah, well, that really vindicates my position.
So let me ask one more thing, and then we'll take a break. Maybe I'll bring him relax from there to come back and talk more about all the work you've done for the healthy.
But one more thing, 63, 64, say, through SNCC, through the nation coming up to Philadelphia.
Did you, at that point, you mentioned in meeting some of the folks who were purported to be not represented.
So you had a sense that maybe these guys were not who they said they were.
And finally in that broad context, did you have an active sense even then that you might have become yourself a person kind of who, you know, FBI and all of those guys were watching?
Oh my god, they came to me. It was not very subtle then.
No, in fact, I've never asked for, I've never made a request for my file, which I guess I should do at some point.
But the FBI came to my, when I started the Freedom Library, I'm sitting there and there come to me about James Forman.
You know they're just moved to get white churches to give money for reparate, whatever it was at the time.
And I just said, you see that I'm here trying to start a school for kids.
I haven't broken any laws. And if you think that I'm going to give you information to deal with James Forman, first of all, I don't have any such information.
And secondly, you know, you guys can't, you know, when we called you, when people were being lynched and you said you couldn't do anything, but you have time now to try to pin something on a guy who hasn't broken any laws yet.
But you want to build a case? What is this? So they huffed out.
And I knew at that point the fact that they came, and there was another thing to let me know, when I came back to Philly, I was trying to get a job somewhere.
And the guy said, you're on the pink list. You're on the pink list because they had me as both a Muslim and a communist and radical, some kind of stuff they had.
And I, you know, so yeah, I have known. And another thing too, I went back to visit. I forgot what year it was. I went down south to visit either in 66 or 67.
And I don't even remember when. And people told me that the FBI had been in touch with them and said that I was coming and probably coming to FOMET violence. I mean, it was just that.
And I think, again, you know, I'm my, I cannot be accurate about my years. I mean, I tried to be as accurate as I could be in that. But some of these events, I can't tell you really what year it was.
But I know it was after I had been back in Philly and decided to go back to visit and folk from there said the FBI told them watch out. He's coming. He's, you know, it was just ludicrous.
It was just, and it tickles me because I've never had a gun, never owned a gun, never advocated that anybody have a gun. I was not, I never advocated non violence in the sense that John Lewis did and does.
But I never advocated violence. It was, it was the kind of thing I always would think about what would I do if somebody attacked my mother?
Forget me. What would I do if somebody attacked my mother and I'm in the room? I'm going to sit there and pray for them. You better not think that. Or my kids. What am I going to do if somebody comes in here to attack my kids?
So rather than take a position, pro violence, anti-violence, I said nothing on issue. Rather, I talked about creative violence versus destructive violence. But anyway, that's.
I'll tell you I can go far. We're back on after short break. I wanted to pick up with with your vision and the perspective and goals that you add in your freedom, freedom life.
Okay, I wanted to do a couple of things. One is my experience in SNCC and with the Black Muslim movement in Atlanta particularly.
Made me see that Black history was something that not only energized me, but energized people that I met who had no sense of their history, who were just thinking they were stuck in a rut.
And I saw people change their behavior. I saw people begin to have hope for the future and to begin the plan for that hope.
And so I thought that a library of books buying about Black people right on Rejavano and a heart of North Philadelphia, two blocks away from projects, high-rise projects.
Next door to a bar would be the perfect place to begin to have people feel better about themselves. And so I looked at it from purely a, it was a faulty analysis, but nonetheless it was an analysis that the problem with Black people was we didn't know our history.
And if we knew our history we'd be better off. Of course that is the most fallacious proposition one can have, but hey, I was young, I was still what, 2021 I forgot, I was in my early 20s.
Okay, so that was my rationale and the school type thing, when we started, before I talk about the school, when we started we were just collecting books, buying about Black people and beginning to put them up in the library.
And then we had Wednesday night history classes and we'd have a delts and Wednesday nights were fun because we would get people from the bar next door.
And what was wonderful is I began to look at people differently, all my life, people who hung out in my mind, people who hung out in the bars were drunkards, whatever.
And this is of course before, I believe it was before cheers was on the air. So I learned before cheers came on that people really like bars because everybody knows their name.
And so when we had our Black history lectures, people from the bar would come over and would share their knowledge.
I mean, you can't tell based on who knows what. And so sometimes I would have done my homework and my research and I'd begin to hold forth.
And God from the bar next door said, no, no, no, no, that didn't happen until 1875. This is what happened, bang, and he starts talking.
And then the other people would chime in, oh yes, well that was, have you read such and such John? No, I haven't. Well, I won't bring it to you next week before you talk to us again about this, you need to read.
And so it was a wonderful, it was both humbling and exciting because it helped me early on to realize you're not here to solve a problem.
You're here to learn and elicit from people what they know and empower them to do what they need to do.
And so your job is to provide an opportunity and take that same opportunity yourself to learn, to learn where people's heads are, to appreciate them, to encourage them.
And so I learned so much from those early sessions, which were really booked as I'm going to teach you Black history. That's how I started.
And it got to be, let's talk about Black history and let's hope I can learn some along the way. And it was just wonderful. Then, then there was a situation where there were some kids who needed some tutoring.
So we started, I wasn't doing any tutoring, I just let, you know, people wanted to do it. And there's one day there were a bunch of kids in there and the tutor didn't show up.
And I got stuck, I couldn't let them go home, I started tutoring and then the next day the person didn't show and then I was tutoring. And then in tutoring the kids I'm discovering, I'm trying to help them with work that they don't understand.
And they can't understand it because three steps back, they didn't get that. So if I'm going to help them as a tutor, I've got to go back those three steps and build them up to where they are.
And forget about what their homework is and go back and give them the fundamentals that they need so that they can catch up. And I started doing it. And of course that sort of lent itself to, I'm doing this with kids who are in school and not having a great deal of success because it's hard.
It's hard to be in sixth grade with a third grade or fourth grade understanding and not getting it and trying to bring you up to snuff in a short period of time.
So the idea came, let me start with some preschool kids who haven't been to school yet, haven't been corrupted by the terrible, egregious education system.
And so I didn't know anything about teaching preschoolers. So there was a teacher that I knew and I asked her to come through and teach. She said fine. And she was using the look-safe method and she was working with the kids. And I'm watching them sitting there and then what all of a sudden she can't do it anymore.
She's like, I can't do this anymore. I got to work. I can't do this. So I started with the look-safe method and I said there's a way, how did I learn to read?
And I remember that standing up at the blackboard with Mrs. Freed in first grade talking about going through the phonetics of the alphabet and then putting an A in front of it and an E.
I went, how that came back to my memory, I don't know. I started working with the kids on phonetics and then I discovered the Lippincott book series. There was, in those days, books put out by Lippincott which would have, which if you use their system, had kids reading two years above whatever anybody else was reading.
It was just wonderful. I bought the series, started with, and I started working with kids and getting excited about the fact that kids could start with phonics and you could move them into reading.
My kids were my own kids, my own kids were guinea pigs for this and they were reading, gee with, my youngest son David was reading at about a year and a half.
My other kids were also, and what I loved about the Lippincott books was that they would hit you with new stuff all the time and they teach you how to deal with the AU. What does that sound?
It was just, it's like I found a miracle. And so then we started talking about, okay, let me set this up. So we started teaching four days a week, two hours a day. And what I did in starting the school was just go in the neighborhood, like the Pied Piper.
And I would go to people that I had worked with on trying to get them to do rent strikes and history who lived in neighborhoods and said, hey I want your kids. You got little kids between two and a half, you know, long as they don't pee on themselves I got them. I can work with them. No diapers, you know, two and a half to five I'll take it.
So I just started teaching those kids every day, four days a week and just for two hours and focusing on reading and focusing on math. And after I did that for about two years I just, you know, incorporated, you know, got a little, got my friend was a lawyer to incorporate Freedom Library, day school ink.
And I started having kids come and I remember when the school opened I had 10, 15, 20 kids that I would do for free. And when I said, okay, it's now $10 a week. And I knew that $10 a week even then was cheaper than any babysitter. And for $10 a week I'll feed your kids lunch. It's five days a week. I'll feed them lunch.
And I know all you got to do is bring them and pick them up and I'll take care of them for the whole week. And I had three students. And I worked on those students. I remember distinctly sitting in the Freedom Library praying, God, if you will give me 10 students. I might be able to make a living at this.
And he never gave me 10. It was 3, 3, 3, and then it was 14. Then it moved to something like 20 something. And when it got up to, I think I was teaching up to 35 or 40 kids in a single classroom. And then I grabbed my mother who always wanted to teach. And she took the older kids, I took the younger kids.
One of the wonderful experiences that I had in teaching the kids is I would use what's called the individual prescriptive method of teaching. So without knowing what that was, I would, if I was working with George over here and George could read faster and understand what was going on, then the seven or eight kids in his group, I let George go.
And give him work to make sure that he, you know, check him out, listen to him. And then I'd work on the other kids. And it ended up that most of the kids were operating on their own sort of like it was hard for me to group them because there were some kids who were who, let's say that George was up to page 45 and begging for more.
And this guy next to him was on page 14, but plotting along. Somebody might be on page 25. And so what I would do is just kind of spend time with each person and encourage the kids. And it got to be where I finally I had so many kids, I had to group them, but I allowed them to push each other.
So I would have George read if he read very well. And the other kids would want to read as well as George read, I'm making up George. I don't think I ever had a George, but that's okay.
But the fun thing in all of this was I learned about teaching, which was counter to everything that I had ever heard about teacher education.
I mean, the teachers that I met were telling me that my methods were just horrendous. They were not working. My kids were reading. They were doing new math.
They understood what a set was and they knew what a subset was. And so it was, it was really, I was experimenting, but I was, I was energized. And at the same time, I hated it.
I didn't, I never, this is what is weird. I enjoyed the interaction with the kids seeing them learn, but I hated teaching because it was hard work. I'm up at night. After the kids are gone, they all have written homework that I give them.
And I've got to go through 45 books and give each person separate. I can't give one sheet and say do that because everybody's at a different level. The kids who were doing math were at different levels. Somebody had just started long division. Somebody was still on addition or subtraction.
And I had to look and just progressively stay with each kid and make sure that they were being built up in a systematic way. So that meant I had to sit there with these homework books. And get them ready for the next day because when they came to school the next day and I'd give them the corrected whatever they did the night before I had to give them the next book.
I didn't care if you were two and a half years old, you had homework and it was writing, if you know making your A within the lines down, down, across, whatever it was. So it was, it was both exciting and exhilarating and it was, if you ask me then, I enjoy it in retro spec because I'm thinking about it.
But I remember distinctly hating it, but I had to do it. I couldn't quit and I did it for 14 years and then quit. I was burned out at the end.
Did it feel like a radical project to do that?
No, it was, it was, it was what was necessary. It was what they needed. I wanted to, I wanted to give them not only during this period, I ran into other nationalists who had schools.
And their emphasis was on, in my view, on rhetoric. And so they had all of the black stuff and they had the drums and they had this. I had none of those things. My thing was, you got to have skills and you got to know about your blackness.
So it was history, it was, you know, you need to be strong in character and I always push those character traits, you know, honesty, integrity, you know, hard work, you know, all the stuff.
And smart work, not necessarily hard work, but smart work.
So those were the things that I pushed. And in dealing with other educators who were working with kids and I had, I had real issues with Amari Baraka, who, and his mentor, out in California.
Why am I forgetting his name because I've read him and did some doctoral work related to some of his ideas.
Well, I could, Karanga, Ron Karanga. I was very concerned that, that kids be, that skill sets be built as well as an ideological base.
And I just thought that they spent too much time on an ideological base without giving the kids the skills. And so the kid can tell you by root whatever it is that he tells you.
I'd rather the kid tell you by root his timetables and stuff that he can use when he's navigating in the world.
And I got together with some other people and we formed the, the CB, the Council of Independent Black Institutions.
And that was in the 70s. I can't tell you exactly when at 70, maybe 71, 72. For two years, I set up a teacher training institute and just using stuff that I did, got them to come to Philly at the Freedom Library Day School.
And from 6am to 11am in night, we had a two week training course for teachers who were in independent black school.
And they had to learn how to, how to teach and stuff that they had to do was how to make a black board.
So that you know, you can start from scratch. You don't have any money to be equipped like a regular school would be, but you know, how do you get the black board paint and how do you, you know, answer we would make the black boards.
We would, and we use the church around the corner and you make room dividers, you know, physically make room dividers.
You would have to go out in the neighborhood and recruit kids and we do it in the summertime.
You go out in the neighborhood, you recruit, you talk to parents, you recruit the kids, you tell them we're doing this Freedom School is going to be for one week.
I think we did the school for one week, but they had a one week training before that and then they had training while they were doing the one week.
And the object in the end was so that when they walked away they had a real sense of what does it take to start a school, what do you need to do, how do you work with the kids, how do you work with the problems that they present to you.
There was very little theoretical, I mean, there was some theory. I tried to give them an overview of what they could expect, but you know, and that the things that you are to expect, you've got to figure, you've got a week to overcome.
You've got a week to overcome a situation with a child who comes in, who everybody says is learning disabled and you cannot treat him or her as if they're learning disabled.
You have to treat that child as if and you must demand from that child the same thing you demand from the kid next to him who is not learning disabled.
And what I've discovered, what I did discover in those days is, and I had a number of children who came to my school like that.
Every one of those children who came like that left, I'm not going to tell you they were A students, but they were C students. They could hang in anybody's elementary school and do C work.
And as long as they could see their way through, they'd be fine.
So lots of things came out in that.
It's really good to have you talk about that because I can see the investment and all the work that you did across those years.
Let me pull you back to 64, 65, 66.
Because while you're starting the school work, the library is also becoming, as I understand, and I need you to tell me if this is correct or not.
So I don't think of a real kind of locust for lots of folks with lots of interesting ideas we're thinking hard about strategies for moving forward.
I know that people across the spectrum of black nationalism, separatism, and it will, some of that effort will build towards in February 66 the creation of black people's units.
Oh yes, yes, got all about that.
And so I'd love to have you talk a little bit about how the momentum gathered to lead to the creation of black people's unit movement, I think Julian Bond is your keynote or perhaps, that's right.
That's right, that's right, that's right.
Just have you tell that story.
Okay.
And part of, and this is good.
During this period when we're doing that, we've been working with gangs, we've been working with, in our work with gangs, I got to know Father Paul Washington of the Church of the Advocate who has a history of his own here in Philadelphia.
He's deceased at this point, but he was, he was the guy in North Philly as a priest who let us have room to voice our nationalism.
And that was unique because most churches, I mean, there was anybody else who was about to have us even meet, we were tainted, I mean, just to, and he was, he was open.
He had his own views, but he, he really worked hard at, at being open and seeing, you know, positive progress.
So in my work with the gangs, there was, there was a friend of his who offered to give me a salary to do that.
So I'm like, you know, I got kids, I got a wife, I, I, I needed it.
So I took the funny, it was a little bit, but I could, I could, hey man, you give me 25 bucks, I can do a lot of it.
So there was, that happened. And as I was working with the gangs, the, the donor wanted one thing.
And as I was working with the gangs, I'm seeing something else. I'm seeing, I can develop these guys into real leaders who can do some positive things in their community.
They can, you know, the violence thing is just a piece of it. I remember having a conversation with one gang member and I'm, I'm passionately trying to tell him about, help me get this, this treaty with this other gang.
He looked at me, he said, John, gang warring is my life.
That's all I have. That's what I live for. You take away gang warring from me. I have nothing.
And I couldn't answer him. I couldn't tell him, well, if you prepare yourself, you know, you could do this. He was giving me his gut.
And I was silent. I couldn't answer him. And so that made me go back to the drawing table and say, okay, what lies beyond peace?
If I don't want him to gang, well, what do I have to offer this guy that can be part of his life that makes sense to him?
And so my first thing is, okay, we need people who will protect people in the community. You can use your skills.
We need old ladies protected and not molested or bothered or robbed.
And they got interested in that. I mean, it was a role. It was like, we need our own police. It was getting to that level.
Yeah, getting to that level. And it's like, you know, and I remember this guy bought into it.
It was, well, when the guy who was funding the program saw that, he said, oh, no, this is not, this is not what I'm paying you to do.
And I said, wait a minute. You paid me because I was doing work with the gangs that I thought was necessary.
I'm not going to do what you want me to do that is not in the best interest of these kids I'm working with.
And so he cut the money and he sent Paul Washington to tell me in a nice way, you know, either shape up or, and I told Paul,
I mean, that's when I had a confrontation with Paul about, man, you better figure out what sides you're on.
You can't be a go-between. You have to take sides. You're either with a community or you're with your church and with the people who are oppressing this community.
You got to make up your mind where you are. And I knew by having a conversation that that could mean I can't use this church anymore.
And I just, it was, this is what we had. And he thought about it. He controlled himself. I knew he wanted to say, man, I, do you know what I've done for you?
But he didn't go there. He listened to me. He was thoughtful. And he just said, okay, well, you know that I'm not in charge of the money.
You know, you know, you've just blown, I said, fine, I've done that, but I still need a place to meet. And he said, okay, fine, you can still use the advocate.
And so I just kept doing what I was doing. And in that process, we talked about a black unity movement. And what we wanted to do was we wanted a movement that could include gang members, that could include old ladies, young people,
professionals, people who were aspiring for politics. We wanted to have people who were musicians or dancers. The thing that made the B-Pum, the black people's unity movement different from every other movement that I've known about, is that we tried to make it inclusive.
So we had Arthur Hall, who was a famous African dance, he had a famous African dance troupe. We had John, the guy who started Freedom Theatre here in Philadelphia, John Allen.
We had his group, so we had artists, we had musicians, we had people who were aspiring for political, one of the guys who actually who ended up running for political office and becoming a state senator, state rep in this area, Richardson.
David P. Richardson was one of the young guys at the time who was part of this. And we had lawyers, we had doctors, we really had. And we tried to get people to see, what is it that, how can we look at each other and not alienate each other, be alien from one another.
We had that represent the interest of the group we represent here. So if I'm a doctor, don't tell me to sing, come by, yeah, that's not what I hear before.
How much room was in there for ideological diversity across? How much?
Oh, there was lots of, because what I was interested in at that point was getting people together. And one of the things that I learned about getting people together is, you get, I mean, you get seven people in a room, you're going to have 14 points of view.
So if you're not ready to tolerate 14 points of view, and what I was always interested in is, what's the bottom line? What can we find that we all agree on? We never tried to take a position as the black people's unity movement that was so radical that people who were in it couldn't buy it.
So what we were really pushing was just, how do we work together, what kinds of programs or things that we can come up with that we can all say, hey, that's a good idea.
And if there are real estate people who say, hey, we need to educate black folks about buying property. Well, nobody's going to argue with that. Let's do that. Let's have a seminar on that.
Yeah, let me ask about that year of 66, which has a whole lot of very, a lot happens in 66 around this effort. But to set the stage for that, I have read that the black people's unity movement was organized around two founding principles. And they have to be really illustrate the strength of feeling and perspective about the nature of the US culture and society at the time.
And what one possible happening forward would be for black Americans. One principle was that white supremacy and racial inequality were constitutive of US culture that they were part of the culture of the nation very forward.
And that had to be acknowledged and confide and related to that was the fact that there are progress wrapped in the Americans, dependent on large part on intracuracial resources that goes of earlier conversations about some Lewis.
And just as the movement really starts to move forward, February of 66, it's not money. Many ones later before there's a massive police raid in coming right after that movement and its close affiliates. And some very interested in having you talk a little bit about how you felt you were reaching forward and then that raid and its implications.
Well, you're talking about the infamous SNCC Dynamite case. It's very interesting. One of the things that had happened while we were doing the school was there was a guy who came who was called Casamiro Parirra.
We discovered from one of our informants that he was a police plant. We didn't know this before. He came and he wanted to set up a thing where he would have martial arts for the young people.
Well, I wasn't opposed to that. It's okay. But then he started talking about, well, I've got some M16s that I want to bring to the school. Oh no, my man. No, we don't need rifles. We don't even need fake rifles. Much less real rifles.
And I kind of watched him and other people who were around kind of watched him. Somebody saw him sitting up in the police having conversations and they got it back to me.
And I never said anything to him that I knew that he was a police informant. But there were always attempts during that period. People would float in and try to instigate some kind of stupid something to try to get you hung up.
And it was lots of situations where people would buy it. In fact, I believe, and I don't know this for a fact, but I believe that the guy who got arrested on the dynamite case somebody posing as a construction worker went to him and said, look, I got this dynamite.
I said, oh my God, you can't have that. Well, would you hold it for me? I don't know what to do. And then that's when it, and then they stuck it on him. The raid was this guy talked to me. And I'm telling him, man, don't have nothing to do with nobody's dynamite.
You leave it where you found it. Let the police know that it's there. It's probably a setup to put you in trouble. Oh, man, I can't call the cops, man, because the guy is out of it.
And I think in that case, the guy was a police informant who said him, but anyway, in the meantime, the police used that. Rizzo was the police chief at the time before he got to be mayor.
And he came to the Freedom Library in 66, yeah, about February. Yeah, because my wife at the time was very pregnant. And they just about one o'clock in the morning broke down the door.
Absolutely, right upstead. And they just broke down into a came up the steps, bulletproof vests and the sort off shot guns. And I happen to be up. I don't know why I was up at one o'clock in the morning. My God, it would have been a mess if I had been asleep and awakened by this. And up in our face. And I was concerned about my wife and my wife was just horrified by it. And she was angry. And she started.
You know, fussing and I'm like, look guys, we'll talk about this in a minute. If you got a search, will you search the bedrooms where I can put my wife there? And I'm thinking, I don't want to die tonight because if she says something and you guys hit her, I can't live with her if I don't do something.
You know what I mean? It's just one of those things. And so I just kept talking quietly and calmly. And I guess I was in shock. You know, when you're in shock, you don't really feel you just trying to solve a problem. And that's where my mind was. It's like, okay, let me cooperate with you. You need to search. I didn't even ask them what they were searching for.
I just said, would you search the bedroom first? Let me put my wife in there and close the door. Then you can do whatever you need to do. So finally, they let that happen.
As soon as that was calm, here comes the captain up the steps. And he thoughts all over again. And he's pushing me around trying to get me to do something stupid. Just, well not really stupid. They just want me to say something.
And they'll call it resisting arrest. And I'm like, you know, what is it that you have to do? Just do what you need to do. I'm not resisting anything. I'm here. I don't even know what this is about. And I didn't fuss. I didn't complain. I didn't say anything.
And they thought, I'm tearing, I'm sealing down and I found out later they were looking for dynamite. So eventually they left. They couldn't get a rise out of me.
Now, I'm going to tell you, I didn't feel the terror until they walked down. I couldn't sleep for nights on end because every sound that came into the street, I'm like this.
I called my lawyer and I saved my lawyer because he was a friend and he was in the Black People's Unity movement, William Lee Acres.
And last I heard he was a federal magistrate in California. But William Lee Acres, I've always trusted him. He was just a straight shooter, good lawyer, tough guy.
And he, I called him up and told him about everything and he said, John, they had a warrant. There's nothing we can do.
And when he told me that, I just said, okay, that was a big moment for me because I was enraged, I was traumatized. And my feelings were hurt.
And he was like, how have I behaved in this neighborhood? I've never had a gun. I've never talked in all of my militant speeches. You'll never hear me talk about rise up and kill the crackers.
But that wasn't my rhetoric. It was never on that level. So I mean, so a lot of feelings going on. And I flip back to the night of the thing.
And when the cops left, there was a big group of people outside who were ready to confront the cops. And I calmly, even though I was upset, said, look, we're going to handle this in a legal way. Please go home. They want you to do something.
They're prepared for you to do something so that they can, you know, mow you down, basically. And so they disperse and went home.
And when my lawyer told me there was nothing I could do, I had to make a decision. And the decision I made was, I'm not going to let my hurt feelings. I'm not going to let my pride and all the things that, you know, I was, I was violated.
I can't let that mess with me because there is nothing that I can do. I mean, I can make noise. I can fuss about it. But it's wasted energy. And I will be getting off track from what I need to be doing to help people.
This is something that happened to you, John. And, you know, you can't get it confused with what you're trying to do for people. And so I sucked it up, basically.
And I was wise to do so.
I want to say this. So it's in the record that that rate. It was August 13, 1966. FBI and police in the city of Philadelphia, the SNCC office, the Freedom Library to the Department.
It was an 80-armed, you know, a riot-year clad of law enforcement officers in the thousand youth from Biden. And I mean, this was really a massive show of law enforcement authority by the white police establishment.
I mean, I'm just going to say, is there a connection between, well, let me ask you sort of to take us forward from that summer of 1966 towards, you know, it's the spring when James Tade is re-elected. No, sorry.
So we re-elected in the fall of 1967. And the spring of 1967, it makes sure it is a police commitment. So that happens. And then in the summer of 1967, that's when David Richardson asks the PUM to help organize high school students. And I don't know if you had a lot of direct engagement of that issue.
No, I didn't. No, I didn't. But you know the story about what happened to those kids.
And then it comes to a certain echo and culmination. Sure.
So maybe you could tell that story. No, I can't because I wasn't really, I tend to, I have learned for good or ill to function with blinders.
And it's like I determined where my territory is. And there are lots of things that happen. There are a lot of issues that come up. And I have disciplined myself to stay focused on, on, on stay in my lane and just focus.
I heard about what was happening with the kids. It was just a, it was like a massacre that went on. But I did not get involved in it. There were some kids who came to the library and talked about it.
And I kind of dealt with those individual kids and, and, you know, talked to them. But I did not try to get into that.
One of the things that that goes back to my mother is always asking me to examine my motives. I always questioned why I would take an action.
So I was never running to get in the paper or running to be quoted. There were times when I was quoted or, you know, but those were things that I did not run toward because I couldn't trust my motives if I were doing that. And it would be like my attitude about certain movement people who sort of looked like they were running around to get press.
I would not go name any names, but particularly right after Dr. Martin Luther King died, there was a certain gentleman who seemed to be in the limelight all the time and had a different story about history than the other people who were there.
But anyway, I always questioned. And so I wouldn't get involved in something even though I might care about it or it might affect me if it was not in the scope of work that I had set out to do.
And if I, if I couldn't answer the question of what's your motive, are you, are you doing that because it's hot now? And I couldn't, I couldn't do that.
How do you, how do you push forward after 66, 67?
I continued doing what I was doing basically. I continued school till 1978. I was the head of B.Pum for a while and then we had a moment. I think in 66 is when I had this Jesus encounter.
And so there was a meeting of B.Pum, which I just kind of shared with everybody that, hey, this is where I am and as long as I'm chairman, we're going to use Jesus' leadership principle.
And somebody in the audience said, well, how do we get rid of you? I said, it's as simple as voting me out and they did. And I felt very good about that. I mean, I took that Paul in approach. I had, you know, was across the Christ. I had been evicted. I was quite pleased with myself.
And so there was a period right after that when it appeared that I lost all credibility. People were calling me, you know, he's crazy, he's a Jesus freak, what happened to John? He's not radical anymore.
And it is precisely that that was the beginning of my real, I think, radical development because I saw Jesus as a revolutionary and I saw him and still see him as one who calls me to account for everything and requires that I make whatever bold moves I need to make for the benefit of folk.
And in fact, and to have the strength to do it by myself, if need be. And if other people come along, know how to treat them and enjoy them, but to stay the course. So that it was an interesting period because after that, that's when people who had been friends kind of dropped off. And I changed the history nights to Bible study nights and people were like, ah, this man has lost his mind.
And that just happened for a while. And as life would have it, I just continued being who I was. And over time, I'm still dealing with issues, still dealing with community concerns. And I'm not doing it in even in a religious being, people expected that at that point, oh, he'll probably start preaching. No way.
I wasn't even going to church. It was a while. That I started going to church and found that very frustrating. So it was a kind of commitment. I'll say that where I have some similarity to John Lewis. I mean, I just stayed the course.
I mean, people were opposed. And I just, hey, this is, this is what I have to do. I'm not angry with you because you can't do it or you don't want to do it. I'm not trying. I'm not an evangelist. I'm not trying to get you saved. I'm just doing what I got to.
Did you participate in the effort that was underway like 60s or early 70s to contest? Try to reorganize democratic party politics to collect more after the Americans in the city or that?
No, I didn't. I had a real bad. I was very anti politics. And and and reason I was is because I had a fresh sense from from snake. I want to see people empowered to do. And what happened? It happened in the poverty.
I'll call it. People came up who called themselves community leaders who might have been. And they got caught in the money. It was all about let's get the funding to do. Everybody was on my funding. And it just drove me to well, I'm going to do this stuff without funding. I'm not asking anybody for money. I'm going to do what I got to do.
And it was amazing that we could get stuff done without funding and other people who were being funded were just being funded.
I think you can come right here and you're leading to the whole war on poverty and other cities funding streams that began to come out of Johnson and the streets.
People people and I just if it was a valid something you know that had to deal with do with connecting directly with people.
Hey, I don't care who you were if you were doing something valid with people. I could support that. I could you know do whatever I could training or whatever you wanted me to do.
But I wasn't going to have to any of the money and I wasn't going to support this camp against that camp. I just had no.
As we say in the black community, y'all got that. Nothing to do with that at all.
Resident will become there at 71. What's your difference in the like the 68s? So at the federal level you kind of see here and build up the.
And Resident's on my thing, the candidate who made some of the same arguments and on the stomach. Very useful for it.
And how do you feel about the community and build up the and not build up the movement forward into the 70s?
Well, in 70s from I was very active. What I would do when things got frustrating for me at the local level, I would do national stuff.
And so the the the CB, the Council of Independent Black Institutions, I got very involved in developing the curriculum and planning for those two years of the trainings and and you know meeting with people and talking about that.
And around and at the same time the the the CBS documentary had been done in 68.
And I think they aired it in 69. So I had some follow up from that people would I got a chance to speak in different colleges.
I had a chance to do work with kids in Chicago. We're actually did some demonstration things which were fun. I mean just meeting kids I didn't know and trying to do it.
And would tell them you know if you don't let anybody come and tell you how to teach kids who isn't teaching kids and why and letting you watch.
I don't know any of these kids. I don't even want to talk to you if you don't have kids for me to work with. And then you can critique me or whatever you want to do but but but you shouldn't listen to anybody who's talking about teaching kids who doesn't teach kids.
So I had a good time in Chicago. I was trying to be mean to the kids. They just laughed at me. They didn't take me seriously. I mean they they knew where I was coming from.
This was post-built. Yeah. So during that period it's sort of like I had a focus outside of Schilling. I mean I could go here I could go there I could work on these these larger projects that would have I thought national impact.
And so those were the things that I was interested in. And I and that was a strong period of the struggle between what I would call revolutionary nationalism and the and cultural nationalism.
And the people out of California and in Newark we're talking about cultural nationalism. So people were supposed to wear certain garb and be African and do this. And I'm talking about revolutionary nationalism.
And what we need to do is to develop politically but we need to develop not within the system the corrupt political system because we can see that it's based on something that isn't cool.
We've got to we've got to test people we've got to train people we've got to have people who whom the community trusts. And then we've got to get the community then to elect them to office outside of the machine.
Well you know that's that doesn't happen in some of the best communities in this country. You just can't beat the machine. And it's not just Chicago. It's filling its New York. Atlanta is wherever you are.
Very very. And it still is. It still is. It still is. So during that period the national work was what kept me and I've I've tend to have that that view that whenever I run in if I'm working on a project and I run into a snare or a stump.
There's a place where I can't go anywhere. I let it sit for a minute and go do something else. And by the time I get finished doing this something else I come back to the other project and I can go with it.
So I that's one of the ways that I keep myself from being discouraged. You know there's always something to do and it's just a matter of focusing on that one thing or two things and doing it when you get into something that you can't go any further.
You go back to the first thing and you can move that forward. So that's pretty much what I did in those years.
Dr. Churchill thank you for such generous contribution. I want to spend some time as you would like as much as you would like to be talking about.
You have been really forged a clear remarkable commitment to community and have been involved in so many efforts to carry the community forward.
And I'd love to hear about some of the things that have been occupying most of your energies and efforts for some time now.
Okay. Thanks for the opportunity.
Right now or when I say right now between 2006 and now there's been a I've been very interested in well maybe I should start before that.
And there was a period in my life and in about 1995 I was in a serious car accident.
And it I was supposed to die but I didn't.
And it really by this time I was practicing law, you know I had a law degree, I was practicing law.
And it really helped me kind of refocus again on what was really mattered in life, what are the points.
And after that experience I got interested in taking theology to another level.
So it was not a change in my commitment.
But it was okay I think it's time for you John to kind of do some study of theology, kind of go to seminary, kind of kind of get that together.
Not necessarily to be a preacher but just for your own philosophical theological development.
And so that experience did more than anything to help me realize that the practice of law was not fun.
I was not having fun. And in the practice of law I was I did some very interesting thing.
One I started out as a farm worker attorney for these.
So there you go. Start out as a farm worker attorney in New Jersey.
And that reminded me of being in Mississippi and in Georgia because in the the the the early 90s South Jersey
Cumberland County and Salem County were to be out at night and to be a lawyer representing the farm workers was like asking for somebody to shoot you.
So after a year of this I couldn't take it.
Just the fear family just honestly the fear factor.
Let me come to Philadelphia and practice law and fill it.
Let me start a practice that deals with the elderly and you know a state planning which was really what I wanted to do.
So when I came here to do that then I got involved in criminal law which I had in plan to do.
And so I'm working with a lot of young people who are being charged.
And I'm getting interested in the kids. I'm taking their cases. I'm fussing with them. I'm trying to get them to come to the office.
I'm trying to figure out how I can you know when I get you past this case I need you know I need you to come and work with me.
I need you to you know and it becomes very frustrating. So by the time I had this accident in 95 it was like you know what I need to do something different.
I really need to move in another direction. I didn't know what to do.
And so the accident sort of slowed me down enough that I at least had a chance to think about it.
So I began to develop what's called the Church for Leadership Institute. I started talking about leadership training and I got involved in okay.
Let me take these biblical principles that Jesus taught and that Moses taught and that the prophets taught and all the good guys, the wisdom books.
How do I translate this stuff so it isn't religious but it's just practical sound advice that people can use.
I don't even have to call it what it is. I can just say you know teach it from that. So I started getting interested in that.
Still wanted to do this whole thing about black education in terms of you know kids and what's happening in our schools and you know just try to figure out how to work that in.
And so I was on this sort of development and by the time the so I went to Lutheran Theological Seminary and while I was there I got disturbed by fellow students.
I'm not trying to get looked at by a bishop. Some they are and I just didn't have much patience with folks who could not see their role as leaders of a community and that it was that the bishop.
I'm not saying be be bad to your bishop. I'm just saying that there ought to be a calling that is people centered and that allows you to have a commitment to the people in your congregation and to serve as a leader of that congregation to help people do the kinds of things they need to do in their communities.
So while I was there I had an opportunity to think more deeply about getting heavier in theology and of course I had a couple of good professors but I wanted to do something you know after I had my courses and my basic reading that I had done on my own and find a raise these issues in class you can raise them but students didn't want to discuss it because it's like that's you know I just wanted to do that.
I just want to get my piece of paper and get out of here. This is a graduate level thing. So I went to union, not union, since in that I did school in Union Institute and University and started a study in black and African African.
I took on American studies. At the same time I took online courses at why am I blanking at another university.
We have your CV in the records. So I was doing the theological courses and the black history stuff and I began to develop wanted to talk about and think about an issue that was interesting to me which was the relationship of religious thought
to whether people are quiet or active whether they're self-liberative. And so I did my thesis on that which was quite interesting. You could find cases on both sides where there were folks who used as we did in SNCC I would say who used the gospel to empower them to fight.
And there were other cases and terrible cases and particularly in mining towns where that was used to keep the miners from really revolting and keep them down.
So that kind of thing I ended up I had a chance to teach at Lutheran Theological Seminary for a year. It was a very discouraging process. They didn't like me and I didn't like them. But it was a good experience and I learned from other colleagues who were teaching in other places when they told the truth.
Nobody really wants to learn. It's a mill and people are coming in and they're going out and they're just trying to get their piece of paper and so don't be frustrated. But I was frustrated because I'm one of those people who I'm not quite a purist but it's like if you're in a theological institution it seems to me that you really ought to be committed to knowing as much as you can know having as many tools in your hand as well.
Because you can't solve a problem anyway. None of us by ourselves can solve any problem. We can have the greatest ideas in the world but we need each other to put in our best thought to the thing to do it. And if you're not going to give it any effort my God and you're a leader what is happening.
Anyway to move forward in 2006 actually in 2005 I started a little church called Liberation Fellowship Church of Jesus and it was a non-religious church in the sense that yes there is word. I have a sermon every Sunday and it is taken from the Bible but it is related to practical leadership lessons.
I always talk about it in terms of leadership lessons. So we've had in our first services we had Muslims, we had atheists, we had all kinds of folks who would just come because it was kind of different in front of us. We had it right here in this place where people just, you know, it's not just a sermon. After the sermon we have a question and answer period people are able to express themselves.
And then we have Bible study and the Bible study is not this is this, you know, it's not like this is what you want to get out of this. It is what do you see? What is the say to you? How does it speak to you? What do you get from it? How does that relate to your life?
And it seems like people were kind of energized by that and could look at things a little deeper than the regular religious labels.
And out of that the early congregation said, hey, why don't we put together a community development corporation and we're here in Germantown, why don't we do that? So the whole, all of us, all five of us, or six, I think our biggest number was seven.
And we all pitched in and everybody had to write a piece of it. Everybody had to, it was a collective document at the end so that everybody got the experience of putting together a CDC and finding out, of course, I help people with this, it has to be this, it has to be that, but you're going to help put it in.
And so we filed and we got our 501C3 thing and people felt really good. I mean, hey, they were involved in the process. And so the next thing was, what are we going to do with this thing? And we started, I remember, in fact, I was just talking to Nancy about this, was it yesterday, sweetheart? One day, just talking about, gee, I remember one new year's Eve talking about with my wife, what are we going to do?
We've got this 501C3 thing and we said we were going to do these things. And we just had this long conversation and we started the next day, New Year's Day, planning how to really get that done.
And so what we've been doing since then is we have a, we have a, an HIV AIDS program, and I call it a program, but it's community education.
And so, in the education, Nancy and I both went to take our little courses to be certified as testers. And so, and as counselors, HIV AIDS counselors. So we, factors back in June, we had a, we had a health fair in the, in Vernon Park, a couple of blocks from here.
We tested people and we had folks come through and, you know, we had some testing for ear hearing, we had, we had a dental truck out there, we had people testing for hepatitis, we, you know, just kind of.
So that's one of the thrusts that we, we do that. Another thing is we started the Greater Germantown Business Association.
And I'm the, I keep calling myself the interim president. There's a guy who says, you just get rid of the interim church bill, you know that you're the president. My theory is that one day, we will really happy elections and, you know, folk from the community will take hold.
But as it is now, it's, I'm, you know, I'm just doing, but we have a good group of people, we have, the history of that, there used to be a Germantown Business Association years ago. And it deteriorated because there were, most of the people were real estate people who were trying to control property.
So they would have arguments at meetings and any little guys coming in would get caught in the crossfire. They just banned it. And when we were talking about community development here, economic, sustainable economic development in Germantown, it's like, wait a minute, we can't, as a CDC, talk about that unless there is a partner who, you know, we've got to have the business community involved in this.
So we looked around to see who was around and there's nothing, nothing was going on. And so we started the Greater Germantown Business Association. And my wife and I went door to store to store and to try to get people interested. And when we went out there, people looked at us like we were nuts as, it's not different than in the 60s when you first go out, people look at you like you're a nut and you just keep going back, you keep going back, you've given them a lot of money.
So we said, this is the literature, we need to do, we're having our first meeting here. These are the things we're going to be talking about. And so at our first meeting, we had like 43 businesses show up. We said, oh, this is great. And we talked about people signing up and, you know, paying their annual dues. And at the next meeting, we had with three people, four people. But since we started, we have never not had our monthly meeting except for July or August.
So the association is growing. We've got some good strong businesses in it. One of the things that we're concerned about is having in Germantown and inclusive, diverse business association that reflects all the cultures. We've got, we've got Arabs, we've got Muslims, we've got Africans, we've got Asians, we've got specifically, we've got a good Korean business community.
They don't live in the area, but they're here. And our job is to try to make everybody feel at home because this is a, this is a very diverse neighborhood. So that's our goal with that. So we've been, we've been pushing that and it's been growing. In fact, now one of our biggest projects, the things that I'm most excited about now, is that the Liberation Fellowship Community Development Corporation has turned out to be a great place for us.
The Liberation Fellowship Community Development Corporation has taken on the task of redeveloping a place called Town Hall. It's here in Germantown at 59, 28 Germantown Avenue. It is, it is the oldest town hall in the state. Quakers found Quakers and Minonites, founded Germantown. Yeah, there were Quakers and Minonites who founded Germantown and I'm going to get the year wrong, but it's 16, I think it's 1681.
It's one of those. Within seven years of its founding, the birthplace of the anti-slave movement was right here in Germantown before filling with the city. And then it got incorporated into Philadelphia. It had a town hall. So that building has been here, not that same building, but on that spot there was a town hall from the 17th century.
And what happened is that the city, it was a civil war hospital. I mean, it still was a town hall, but the only battle we had in Germantown, it was that there was the hospital down the hall, taking care of people on both sides of the aisle.
And so it has a lot of history and it has been lying in disrepair since 1994-95. And we have developed a project to acquire the building and when we first mentioned this in 2008 or 2009, it's when we came up with the idea.
And our councilwoman laughed us to score. You got $35 million.
And I just felt impelled. My wife went along with me, but she was like, I think you've been smoking something when I wasn't looking job.
But I mean, I had this vision. It had to happen. And so there was this whole low now in 2011. When I go to people with the idea, we've got a team of people, we've got architects on the team.
I just had a meeting last week with the mayor's office of sustainability here in Philly. She wants more information, but there is not a year crazy. It is a hey. Have you thought about this? Yes, we've thought about that. Have you thought about that?
Oh, no, we didn't. That's a good idea. And she's going to put us in touch with some other people. So it is. That's where I am now. And let me tell you what it's for.
We want to develop the building as a state of the art building using geothermal and solar. It's going to be a green building. It will also be a place for a dual education level.
One will be STEM subjects, science, technology, engineering, and mathematics. And that is for in my brain, I see a rival to MIT right here in Germantown in this neighborhood.
At the same time and in the same place, I want to see green college job training, training in just plumbing, heating, electricity, welding, all the kinds of green things that allow people to earn income at a living wage.
And one of the things that is critical is right across the street from Germantown High School, which is one of the poorest performing high school. And the current district attorney has suggested that town hall should be developed as a criminal justice center, which is basically a court or a place to house people.
The next argument is it ought to be a place when the kids look across the street that they can say, when I leave here, if I'm not going to college and I could take college courses over there, I could at least get some basic skills so that I can be employable.
The two things, and the third thing we want to do in that building is to have a green business incubator. So we want this to be state of the art and that's the other thing, the other avenues that we're involved in.
So that's the project, but it incorporates our interest in environmental education. And so we have that as part of what we do. When the 2011 Brownfields Conference came to Philadelphia, we were one of its sponsors here.
And so that just gives you an idea of some of the things that we're interested in. And so my life is still full, very busy.
So, I'm so afraid from this issue that you have never been someone to sit around and watch the world go by.
No. So, it's going to be a real R and a preparation. Very, very grateful. Thank you on behalf of the museum and the library. This is going to be a great privilege to be with you.
All right, and thank you. It's been fun.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.